[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings and this
morning we are looking at the collapse
of hospitals serving some of America's
most vulnerable patients it's at the
center of an eight-month CBS News
investigation into why essential
facilities are being shut down at such
an alarming rate and what we found is
investors making millions of dollars
while communities are left without a
crucial health care provider our chief
medical correspondent Dr John lapuke is
here with the latest uh John good
morning Good morning Tony last November
our cameras were there the day 95 year
old Delaware County Memorial Hospital in
Pennsylvania closed its emergency room
doors for good with the hospital still
shuttered we returned to Delaware County
to see the impact
Garfield for the past 43 years this
corner of Delaware County Pennsylvania
has relied on the familiar face of
Veteran paramedic Jim McCants all right
Jimmy I understand
so when one of the area's largest
hospitals Delaware County Memorial shut
its doors for good
mccanns took it personally a lot of
nurses I know Pas Physicians it's their
life calling it's really what they want
to do and then just to be betrayed like
this you feel betrayed yeah absolutely I
do and so does I'm sure everybody else
in this line of work feels that way over
what they did they are Prospect medical
Holdings the Los angeles-based company
that purchased Delaware County Memorial
in 2016 with the help of private Equity
investors and a promise to dramatically
expand service to the community but last
November the hospital shut down we were
there the morning 28 year old Cecilia
viswete was turned away from the ER she
was having trouble feeding her
one-year-old daughter because of a
breast infection
they said I should look on Google Maps
for another hospital inside Delaware
County Memorial the hallways and patient
rooms normally bustling were empty
except for a few nurses charged with
cleaning the place out Angela Napolitano
worked there for 41 years until the day
it closed it was sad sorry it was a very
sad day when we recently returned to
Delaware County Jim mccanns told us the
impact had rippled beyond the nearly 85
000 residents the hospital once served
put pressure on the entire Health Care
System the EMS system everybody's
feeling this this really hit hard
start to the ER 501 Lanes down for a
walk-up shooting in January two shooting
victims arrived at the closed ER
a 9-1-1 audio obtained by CBS News
revealed they had to be taken by
ambulance to Lankenau Medical Center
nearly five miles away
McCann said nearby ERS are slammed and
his call volume is up about 25 percent
because he is covering more territory
his team of 16 Medics now needs to spend
more time taking patients to hospitals
farther away where does this end up
leaving the people of this community
they're stranded for Health Care it did
hurt them it's going to continue to hurt
them it's going to cost some of them
their lives the closure hasn't hurt
everyone a CBS News investigation has
learned of a series of financial moves
that enrich Prospect medical management
and its private Equity backers in 2018
Prospect Medical's owners took out a
1.12 billion dollar loan and paid
themselves a 457 million dollar dividend
Sam Lee the CEO of prospect medical took
home about 90 million you found a way to
navigate you making money and leaving
those people
in the lurch
that's what they did it's criminal
morally ethically it should be legally
but it is legal and Prospect medical
then paid off the loan by selling off
the land and buildings of most of their
hospitals to a Birmingham Alabama firm
called medical properties trust just put
simply they bought the real estate out
of Prospect and leased it back to
prospect Rob Simone an analyst at a
connecticut-based investment research
firm says medical properties trust is
where private Equity investors turn
their Hospital real estate holdings Into
Cash the publicly traded company has
built a portfolio of nearly 200 U.S
hospitals often in low-income
communities these are hospitals where
care is needed care is required and
there may be only one option Simone has
advised clients to bet against medical
properties trust but told us he doesn't
trade on the company himself on its
website medical properties trust says
it's at the very heart of health care
but Simone says the firm has several of
its hospitals with unsustainable rents
Hospital systems are struggling in
individual hospitals are closing in some
cases which is very problematic that's
what he says happened in Pennsylvania
where Prospect medical must pay 35
million dollars a year in rent money
that comes out of Hospital operations to
Medical properties trust here's the
hospital we're talking about during our
return visit we drove by Delaware County
Memorial place used to be packed it was
bustling where did they all go Prospect
medical says it plans to turn the
hospital into a behavioral health
facility it says its rent obligation
here in Pennsylvania to Medical
properties trust was not a factor in
that decision the doors remain closed
what would you say to the people who are
trying to keep
the hospital closed where's the
responsibility you took the
responsibility for a Health Care System
you can't just drop that
in a statement Prospect medical said it
hadn't been notified of a significant
increase in EMS response times or if
other hospitals have been significantly
impacted due to the closure CEO samly
declined an interview and to answer our
detailed questions as did medical
properties trust the firm that bought
the hospital real estate in a statement
it said it has no involvement in
operational decisions that the facility
it owns and denied its lease agreements
have caused any of them to cut services
or fail tomorrow will show what happened
at Delaware County Memorial raises
questions about closures elsewhere
is it just begs a question about Equity
here I can't imagine this happening in
Beverly Hills or Greenwich Connecticut
or any of these affluent places in this
country Yale that's exactly what a
Delaware County official said to me she
said this would never happen in a more
affluent community and the other thing
that this raises is the question of
transparence so you know you could say
this hospital it was in trouble it was
in danger of failing when uh it was
bought so that they said the company
that bought it said all right we're
going to sell off the hospital the land
the buildings and we're going to use
that money to reinvest it into the
hospital and and hopefully we'll we'll
save it right except it turns out that's
not exactly what happened we would never
have known except for attorney general
Peter nirona from Rhode Island uh
invoked an unusual law there to open the
books of prospect medical and found out
about that 457 million dollar dividend
should have paid itself we would never
have known about it somebody gets 90
million last time you were saying is
this an anomaly you know how often does
this happen you said that is this an
anomaly and we heard you and we
continued the investigation and we went
to San Antonio we'll tell you about that
tomorrow
that's a good tease Dr John lapuch we
appreciate you